Good morning, John.
This video contains a lot of flashy lights,
and the theme song from the show 'Friends'.
Consider yourself warned!
Okay, we've never done this,
so if we suck,
we've still got the footage.
[crowd cheering]
One, two, one two three go!
So no one told you life was gonna be this way,
your job's a joke, you're broke,
your love life's DOA (Dead On Arrival) !
It's like you're always stuck in second gear,
when it hasn't been your day, your week,
your month, or even your year, but
I'll be there for you
when the rain starts to pour
like I've been there before
I'll be there for you
cause you're there for me too!
Andrew Huang is consistently one of my favourite YouTubers,
he's also in my band,
Hank Green and the Perfect Strangers,
and he roped me into this project
to cover the theme song from 'Friends' in nine different genres.
So if you didn't enjoy mine,
there's probably one that you will like.
Thank you to Andrew for arranging this,
and doing all the production.
Thanks to SIim's in San Francisco, where we filmed this,
and to the Perfect Strangers for performing it with me,
and thanks to Wheezy Waiter, and all of the people in the crowd,
who sent me footage for filming this video.
John, you will see me on Friday,
when we will be resuming our regularly scheduled programming.